Speaker 1: All right. Let's hear from a few
more people. We take calls via discord at
David Pakman dot com slash discord. Let's go
to Schuyler in New York. Schuyler, welcome to
the program. What is on your mind today?
Speaker 4: Okay, David, how's my audio?
Speaker 1: It's beautiful.
Speaker 4: Great. So
I wanted to ask you about the ongoing
battle between Disney and Ron DeSantis. Yes.
On one hand, I do tend to agree that Disney
as a corporation is way too powerful. And
the idea that they can basically self-govern
can be a bit of a red flag. And, you know,
generally there are a lot of other aspects about
Disney that are damaging to the free market,
to labor, to the environment. The other I'm really
enjoying how Disney continues to humiliate the
Santas and the amount of else that they keep
handing him. Now, I don't really think DeSantis
is taking some sort of principled stance in this
whole battle, this whole battle. It's obviously
just cultural and over the don't say gay stuff
and Disney allegedly being woke. But I'm curious,
David, where do you fall in this whole battle?
Speaker 1: I think that I share your concerns with
the idea that a corporation can essentially work
as a self-governing entity. I don't like that.
I think it's not a power that should be delegated
to corporations. And would that I agree 100%. I do
believe that DeSantis and this Anti-woke movement
has overplayed its hand as it applies to Disney
and more generally. There's polling that now I've
discussed a number of times that shows that the
majority of the American public, it's not a huge
majority, but it is a majority actually falls on
the woke rather than the Anti-woke side on a lot
of these different issues, including trans, LGBT,
etc.. So I believe that it is a bad strategic
decision for DeSantis in Florida to target Disney
not only over issues where the the majority
of the country is actually with Disney,
but also because Disney is so beloved. You know,
I hate theme parks, but a lot of people love them
and people like the Disney characters and the
movies and all that. It seems like a bad decision
to pick a fight with Disney tactically as well.
Speaker 4: Yeah. And you know, my biggest like I
don't know if it's a concern or just observation
is is obviously the continued escalation over,
you know, what being anti-woke actually means.
You know, I don't know where it ends. Like at this
point we're having a whole war on like western
society and culture, whether it's education,
whether it's medical science, whether
it's, you know, culture and religion.
I just I don't know where the endpoint is.
Speaker 1: So let me address that. If you
ask people on the right, they would say the
anti wokeness ends when we defeat Wokeness.
My view is that's never going to happen because
the country has become more and more woke. I mean,
when you if we think about Wokeness as sort of
like enlightened left wing ideas, the country
keeps moving more and more in that direction. So
I think anti wokeness ends as those ideas become
less and less common. And when Republicans
realize they're not going to win with anti
wokeness, then they'll move on to the next thing.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's interesting. A lot of the,
you know, sort of corporate wokeness that gets
derided by the right by big corporations tends to
typically only exist in the social sense. And that
a lot of times this corporate wokeness doesn't
really trickle down to like improve progressive
progressivism around labor or equitably 100%.
Speaker 1: And that's because for a lot of these
corporations, they're just taking the view they
determined to be more socially palatable. And
it's because that's what's most profitable.
Speaker 4: Exactly. All right. Well, thank
you very much for taking my call, David.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you.
Great to hear from you. There's
Skyler in New York with a very interesting
and important issues being being brought up